- [Instructor] Sarah Swift
got a speeding ticket
on her way home from work.
If she pays her fine now there
will be no added penalty.
If she delays her payment then
a penalty will be assessed
for the number of months, t,
that she delays paying her fine.
Her total fine, F, in euros,
is indicated in the table below.
These numbers represent an exponential,
an exponential function.
So they give us the number of months
that the payment is delayed
and then the amount of fine.
And this is essentially data points
from an exponential function.
Just to remind ourselves
what an exponential function
would look like,
this tells us that our fine
as our function of the months delayed
is going to be equal to some number
times some common ratio to the t power.
This telling us this exponential function
is essentially telling
us that our function
is going to have this
form right over here.
So let's see if we can
answer their questions.
So the first question is
what is the common ratio
of consecutive values of F?
So the reason why r right over here
is called the common ratio
is it's the ratio that
if you look at any two,
say if you were to increment t by one
the ratio of that to F of t,
that ratio should be consistent for any t.
So let me give you an example here.
The ratio of F of two to F of one
should be equal to the ratio
of F of three to F of two,
which should be the same
as the ratio of F of four
to F of three.
Or in general terms the
ratio of F of t plus one
to the ratio of F of t
should be equal to all of these things.
That would be the common ratio.
So let's see what that is.
If we just look at the form,
if we just look at this right over here.
So what's the ratio of
F of two to F of one?
450 divided by 300, well that's 1.5.
That's 1.5.
675 divided by 450, that's 1.5.
1,012.5 divided by 675, that's 1.5.
So the common ratio in all
of these situations is 1.5.
So the common ratio over here is 1.5.
And another way,
and just to to make it clear
why this r right over here
is called the common ratio,
is let's just do this general form.
So F of t plus one, well that's
just going to be a times r
to the t plus one power,
and F of t is a times r to the t power.
So what is this going to be?
This is going to be...
Let's see, this is going to be
r to the t plus one minus t,
which is just going to be
equal to r to the first power,
which is just equal to r.
So this variable, r,
is going to be equal to this common ratio.
So whether we figured out
that the common ratio is 1.5,
that tells us that our function
is going to be of the form
F of t is equal to a times,
instead of writing an r there
we now know that r is 1.5 to the t power.
1.5 to the t power.
Write a formula for this function.
Well we've almost done that,
but we haven't figured out what a is.
And to figure out what a is
we could just substitute.
We know what F of one is.
When t is equal to one, F is equal to 300,
and so we should be able
to use that information
to solve for a.
We could have used any of these
data points to solve for a,
but let's do that.
F of one is equal to a times
1.5 to the first power,
or a times 1.5, and that
is going to be equal to,
they tell us that F of
one is equal to 300.
And so another way of writing this
is we could say 1.5
times a is equal to 300.
Divide both sides by 1.5
and we get a is equal to 200.
And so our function, our
formula for our function, is,
let me write it in black so we can see it.
It's going to be 200, that's our a,
times 1.5 to the t power.
Now another way...
Well actually let's just
think about the next question.
What is the fine in euros
for Sarah's speeding ticket
if she pays it on time?
So paying it on time, that
implies that t is equal to zero.
Or another way of thinking about it,
we need to figure out her
fine for t equals zero.
So we need to figure out F of zero.
So what's F of zero?
It's 200 times 1.5 to the zero power.
1.5 to the zero power is one,
so that's just going to
be equal to 200 euro.
Now another way of thinking
about it is, well look,
let's look at the common ratio.
To go from 675 to 450
you're essentially dividing
by the common ratio.
To go from 450 to 300, you're
dividing by the common ratio.
So then to go from t
equals one to t equals zero
you would divide by the common ratio again
and you would get to 200.
Or another way of thinking about it
is to go to successive
values, or successive months,
every time we are multiplying
by the common ratio.
Every time we are multiplying,
we are multiplying by the common ratio.